hello and welcome to this video am I on
the right number
no come on let's do that right away it
just takes a second
I came so 95 I'm to record an exchange
exchange a back on short plane very like
them
let's see okay place with an IG to eat
too I usually play differently with the
quick Roxy one the varnish so here what
about this night to be forum is there
like night before this Bishop be one
night see for Queen a for on this
typical stuff so probably I'll just
Castle no egos b3 mmm yeah so how do you
get this Bishop out probably you don't
know there's no real good way to develop
it the other way of playing this is e
five I'm not sure about it because both
nights an hour look a little bit odd
okay Bishop f5 maybe to trade f5 mmm I'm
not certain f5 and
I'd like to get one piece traded I mean
I don't have that much space and trading
one piece like night did so that 97's
may be possible without blocking that
bishop if I get in 97 yeah here the
thing is I can simply take and then
Kauai 5 ok F 4 F 3 is that bad I don't
know
doesn't look bad if 3 I think I should
take this opportunity to destroy while
that destroys strong to worsen his pawn
structure let's put it like that ok
let's see what what's the deal here he's
got the e4 square that's nice for him
mmm how do you play with white with
black here a pieces still look a little
bit odd and the night on b6 is a real
typical Ella kind problem you really
wonder what what you should do with this
piece me awesome he's got age 4 maybe
age four Queen g4 ideas like that
rook f4 is an interesting with him but
okay I'm getting too slow yeah it seems
it seems somewhat he wants to put the
knight on to e6 and that makes a lot of
sense it just just bit it's just a bit
slow okay if I check iam 194
yeah maybe 94
how to how to get close here Bishop h6
Bishop f6 mmm that that didn't look too
dangerous to me honestly even Queen h4
is an option the remaining pieces will
be strong well let's do it
I have no time though maybe Bishop g5
huh ah Bishop g5 oh that time management
yeah that's super really I could have
just taken his six and be completely
okay and then I stumbled into this
nonsense always haters like you have no
problem whatsoever
and you want to do something interesting
and it just like fails completely I mean
like completely fails
I don't think you will take but still
supreme moves you can enter
okay I still have a very good night down
before some I can still be a bit of a
past year and trying to post the art
problem neighbor probably removes it
okay 92 I don't know why that was
necessary just take it off on f4
somehow still in this game not being in
good shape or anything but
okay I'm threatening Knight f3 now when
she has to yeah has to look at and he
did we should be three years an
annoyance I don't have a good square for
the night unfortunately
and I don't King edge one is totally
okay unfortunately I get to see to it
it's still not really doing much ten
seconds
it's that way too
not really my g3 is made
yeah you know that was pretty awful this
is this it's fancy player it's just
unnecessary you just take here yeah and
you're better for nothing
okay I'm equal but with no problem at
all
and then like here and then Bishop g5
great I mean what was really playing
this well I think I mean allowing me to
take on g2 and so on he remit that isn't
that good it's not good okay yeah I
thought actually h4 was the issue but
you didn't do that 94 95 yeah yeah I'm
ok again yeah I just said and this is so
stupid just take it just take it six and
be done with it I mean it's quite clear
that this is good for me yeah at least
it's good compensation I've got very
good pieces now but of course Bishop g5
yeah now I'm completely lost I mean he
played it in a way that I was getting on
some hope maybe maybe I was okay at some
point it was very unnecessary to allow
so here 93 is the threat he's still
better but
yeah the dew point is too strong God
cannot do much there yeah it was an
extremely unnecessary loss absolutely
unnecessary just take it six and I'm
fine I will get this pawn I mean and
then I'm okay I mean I'm not better
maybe but queen g4 seems to keep an
equal game but you know what I wondered
actually is if I have something better
here maybe I should go d5 in this
position because this is actually fine
I'm immediately threatening to take here
and play e5 and then this is also
preferable over if I because here here
white was definitely a better because
both Knights are somewhat misplaced so I
should play d5 in this position okay
guys thanks for watching